[Music]
hey you guys
we're doing a matinee show because
jenny's on vacation
not really but you know so we recorded
this previously
you know what i mean so we decided we
were gonna do some movies that we wanted
to catch up on
some that i had put into the rotation uh
you know for the retrospective but never
got the most votes but that i still
wanted to do
and one of these was the 1999 roman
polanski film
the ninth gate yeah this is a great
movie
interestingly i saw this in the theater
back when it first came out
and i liked it but i didn't love it
um but i've been wanting to revisit it
for a long time and i haven't seen it
again since then i don't think
i've never seen it yeah because i think
you said you thought you'd seen it but
when we started watching it you said it
didn't seem familiar yeah i guess i was
getting
this one um uh confused with uh
what's that one from hell from hell yeah
and then ninth gate i think i was
getting that
confused with like uh that poster of it
wasn't called the gate with the demons
coming up out of the ground
yeah that was like that kid's movie yeah
like kids yeah yeah
i got confused with those two somehow
um but now i saw it and i was like oh
man this is awesome it
it's almost kind of like uh i was gonna
i think i mentioned it at the time
it kind of reminded me of kubrick's eyes
wide shut but better
yeah it definitely has something that
maybe eyes wide shut didn't
have um i don't know i kind of want to
get into it it's funny because i was
watching a couple other like reviews of
it
and they said pretty much the same thing
that it that it was similar to
or it had the same vibe to it because it
has like the satanic cult and we're all
going to the house and everything like
that
so it wasn't just me yeah and actually i
was watching if you guys are not
subscribed to
um grumpy andrews house of horror i love
that guy he's like a british dude
and he did a review of this and he said
the same thing that i said that he had
watched it like when it first came out
and he was just kind of like meh
but then when he watched it again he
loved it and
he said and i actually kind of thought
this i don't think i said it to you at
the time but i kind of thought this when
we were watching it
the one scene where johnny depp's
character dean corso when he first sees
quote unquote the girl
who he calls green eyes the scene where
he first sees her
in that lecture hall very much recalls
the scene
where the protagonist sees the witch
girl i think it's madame
or uh modern lacrimosa in dario
argento's inferno
and i wondered if that was deliberate i
mean i imagine it probably was
because the the framing of it was very
similar and it reminded me of it and i
was watching that review and he said the
same thing and i was like oh my god
i thought of that too but yeah so maybe
maybe that's why it's like an early hint
that
you know the girl is supernatural in
some way
it's kind of like eyes wide shut in a
way
but better it's better because it's more
mission oriented you got
johnny depp he's playing this like a
book an ancient book specialist
and he finds books and sells them uh to
collectors
he knows everything about forgery and
you know
he knows what a book is worth knows
[ __ ] these obscure
uh titles off the top of his head knows
the history behind these all these books
and he's working for i guess himself
he's kind of like a
hired hand or a mercenary and also like
a detective tracking down who has these
books and
it's pretty cool and it's it kind of
drew me
into it because it doesn't have a whole
lot of characters and it's very kind of
like
mission oriented he's got he gets hired
to [ __ ] find these other two books
to match these other this this guy's got
this satanic book
he knows there's two other copies and he
wants them
um or at least he wants to compare him
and he's got to find him and then it
takes him takes johnny depp down in this
journey between all these damn satanists
he's like a really wealthy
european satanist and he doesn't believe
in any of this [ __ ]
but he starts to and um
it's pretty cool it's kind of like a
puzzle too he's looking at all these
books and trying to see the differences
between them and finding little hidden
clues in these
old books there that book is from the
1600s wasn't it
yeah something like that it was written
by um well the thing about it
now this is actually based on a novel uh
it was based on a novel called the club
dumas
by uh arturo perez roberte which came
out in 1993.
it's a loose adaptation um some of the
satanic [ __ ] is the same
but the novel as far as i can tell tell
i haven't read it but i
like watched a couple other people's
summations of it the novel is more
concerned about it has all that satanic
book [ __ ] in it but it also has like a
thing about
a rare edition of the three musketeers
that's a whole other subplot that's in
there
and the ending of the book is very very
different and the way
the book ended seemed uh a little bit
lame so i'm kind of glad that they
changed it
like for the movie so this was
co-written and directed by uh roman
polanski in case i didn't mention that
yeah he's a [ __ ] bird
but well yeah but you can make it down
but he still makes good movies yeah i
know what i mean
he's great in the tenant uh yeah yeah i
said i just got a comment on that the
other day that said i just watched this
movie and i don't understand the goddamn
thing about it
yeah yeah go back and watch it again
yeah well and i kind of feel like well
roman polanski's movies much like
kubrick's movies much like
you know anything like that these kind
of you really need to see him a few
times
yeah and the ninth gate is actually one
of those i'm not saying it's his best
movie but it's actually much much better
than i remembered it being our
generation grew up with hbo
and cinemax being basically our version
of the internet there was no internet so
you just watched the same movies
over and over and over again yeah and
something like a polanski film
gets better every time you see it you go
why'd that happen so then you see it
again
a couple days later and you're like oh
yeah yeah and you're a kid when all this
is going on
that when we were kids and the tenant
got [ __ ] drilled into me
yeah all right this is a movie i would
have liked as a kid
back in that era had they shown this to
us over and over again
oh yeah i'm like oh yeah yeah well it
has
kind of like everything i like about it
i like occult like movies about occult
[ __ ] i love
stories about books and especially like
old creepy
books and like old creepy dudes with big
mansions with big creepy libraries i
love love love that kind of [ __ ]
so this is right in my wheelhouse and i
also love it's almost
it's kind of like a noir it's it's
basically like a detective story
right um it but also with like a satanic
element to it
yeah so yeah he gets this job man to
track down these other two books
from this creepy old super rich dude
boris balkan played by frank langella he
doesn't
tell you at first he doesn't tell you
he's a satanist but he must be a
satanist when you're first meeting him
because
every book that he has is about the
devil and his
library is probably like on the 20th
floor of a [ __ ] skyscraper
and it's all glass and hermetically
sealed and you can walk through there
and there's all these
tomes you know they're hundreds and
hundreds of years old it's got to be
like
based on how much and some of these like
one-offs and old forgotten books
and you know once they kind of establish
how much these books are worth
you look at his library and it's got to
be tens of millions of dollars
sure if not hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of damn books
that nobody else has read because
there's like a couple copies
maybe one copy and he's got it and
this is before internet and uh
they didn't xerox and [ __ ] take
pictures and post on the internet what
was in the book
if you had the book only you knew and
turns out there are books like
that i asked jenny do books like that
actually exist where it's like one copy
or two copies oh yeah
and the dude who owns it doesn't tell
you what's in it that's part of
collecting them
yeah i mean if it's in a private
collection like i know that you know
google books and uh you know
the gutenberg project and stuff like
that have been really trying to
digitize books so people researchers can
access them
but if there's only one or two copies of
a book in the world as is the situation
in this movie
and they're in private collections right
and that person does not want to
digitize what's in there
then probably no one will ever know yeah
and these are like billionaires and
multi-millionaires that own these books
and they're not going to share them
and they're like they're in competition
with the other collectors
to own these books and they're in
competition to kind of like
hide what's in the book it's like for
our own purple you know oh yeah i used
to own that book you know there's that
kind of [ __ ] you know
but if you if you had the book and
nobody else has really seen
it it's just a mystery and the other
collectors are like hating on you
yeah he's got that book you know
i don't know well there's competition in
every subculture i know what it's like
which and it's it's kind of cool that
that the story is set
in this world of these damn collectors
and
and these particular collectors are
extremely rich satanists
and that one dude every his whole
library every book was about the devil
and they were like [ __ ] from the fifteen
hundred sixties and seventeen hundreds
and some of them only he had them and uh
that's kind of a fascinating
subject one of the interesting things
about this movie though and i didn't
really realize
it until i was thinking about it later
but other than boris balkan
who pray like i said he's played by
frank langella and he's the one that
initially hires johnny depp to go on
this
[ __ ] mission or whatever who uh is
real ruthless and will
kill people to get what he wants and
stuff the other satanists
um okay other than lena olin's character
she's a [ __ ]
but some of the other ones that are kind
of like satanists are into the devil
they're not
really that terrible of people i mean
they're more into it for the orgies
yeah i did it for the orgies man yeah
i want to ladies my orgy days are over
a bunch of rich european aristocracy
having these little [ __ ] fests
dressing up and yeah outfits
not unlike the [ __ ] goth fetish scene
yeah it was just kind of like that it
wasn't like oh we're going to eat babies
or anything like that it was just
basically
just kind of like a statement yeah kind
of thing
except like i said except for uh
franklin jealous no we're serious
he well he he was actually even [ __ ]
on
lena olin's character because she was
doing that whole hey we're gonna do all
the orgy with the robes and everything
and he just thought that was stupid
he's like how dare you do this in the
temple of the master
because he was like super super into
yeah yeah yeah yeah but see that's the
thing
you know that he's like shifty from the
beginning
um when he first hires like johnny i
keep calling johnny depp his
character name is dean corso but let's
be honest it's johnny depp yeah i mean
he pretty much played himself he pretty
much plays his own
a little bit more of a serious version
of himself though yeah he's kind of
restricted kind of like
in in from hell except not as english
yeah yeah
in a little bit this reminds me a little
bit of uh secret window too
that uh stephen king adaptation that he
was in right around the same time i feel
like that came out right around the same
time as this maybe a year or two
for you know on the before or after but
so
boris uh summons johnny depp who's like
the best in the business
and uh he summons johnny depp
as one does and uh he's like okay
basically he's like i have this book
which is called the nine gates of the
kingdom of shadows which was written in
the 17th century
by this dude named aristide torchia and
the rumor has it that this book was
written
in collaboration with the devil himself
yeah
he's signed and he's signing it and that
arising torchia was burned
at the stake like back then because he
was supposed to be in league with the
devil and he wrote these books
now he wrote well there okay so there
were a few copies of this book now boris
balkan has one and he's like i'm pretty
sure it's
you know legit but there are two other
copies in the world
i want you to go to europe and find
those two copies and compare them to
mine because i want to make sure
that those other two aren't forgeries
now this
mission and he gives him like a
ridiculous they never tell you how much
money he gives him but he just looks at
the check and he's like oh all right
you know what i mean and he keeps saying
like as it's going along that he
wants to keep adding more and more money
so it's apparently like a [ __ ] ton of
money
and um now this is a little bit of
a misdirection on boris balkan's part as
becomes clearer as the story goes on
it's not entirely
the the reason isn't entirely [ __ ]
he does want the other two books to
compare them
but not because he thinks they're
forgeries
you know what i mean so i mean should we
spoil this this came out a long time ago
yeah i don't care okay i don't really
care
so basically now i will say the the the
first part of this movie
you know where johnny depp is gets
summoned by boris
uh is set in new york and obviously
because roman polanski is not allowed to
come to the united states um
all the new york stuff was either done
on a set as i think as some parts of
eyes wide shut where as well like some
of the new york city streets
um or if it or if they're in a car or
something like that it's a green screen
uh it's not terrible but it is like
slightly slightly distracting
i don't know it depends on how you look
at it yeah i liked everything about the
movie
i did too all right it does take you
into a certain zone
yeah it started for me when you see the
uh the satanist library and he's in the
skyscraper and he's looking out that
glass window and you can see in the
background cars going across the bridge
and
it looked like it was actually on
location if it wasn't
it was a really good signal yeah that's
yeah it wasn't
it wasn't on location you could see some
stars in the sky and in the distance you
see an airplane going and it's very
subtle
yeah you know what i mean it does make
you feel
like you're in a location but it's kind
of like a
stylized location slightly very slightly
it's just
it gave me a kubrickian feel yeah it's a
little otherworldly a little bit
otherworldly kind of like inside
inside the uh the overlook yeah
not quite as much as that but it does
have a like a little bit of veneer of
other worldliness which i think adds a
lot to
the story actually because it has like a
creepy like atmosphere
i'm going to say right off the bat
people i think i think the movie's a
masterpiece
i've never seen it i'm going this is a
matter this is [ __ ] i was loving it
all the way
it pulled me right in and i got a short
attention span i'm not
tolerant to meandering stories or things
that are poorly edited
there's you've got to be really good to
[ __ ] pull me into his tail especially
tale about dude books come on
that's what i was thinking i was
wondering if you would because i'm going
to say too this is a very long movie
like two hours and 15 minutes or
something i got pulled right into it
yeah okay all right it's very mission
oriented which i i i'm into that
yeah and he's kind of like a mercenary
detective
book dude yeah all right he's an expert
at what he's doing which i respect that
so i'm like okay all right yeah
find the [ __ ] book johnny
it has that element to it so very
effective
in getting you interested in these
characters in this story
it's very hard to do especially with me
i'm very resistant
to the to the tricks that they use even
though the simplest
most tried and true tricks are the ones
that work the best on me
if you try to get too [ __ ] fancy i
got that 10
15 minute rule kicks in where if i'm not
feeling it in 10 or 15 minutes i will
never feel it
yeah this one [ __ ] almost right away
and which is interesting because like
you said it's kind of about it's set in
the antique book world
i mean there is like kind of the satanic
[ __ ] on top of it which is kind of cool
and he's being followed by people and
people like are ending up murdered so
that's like pretty exciting
but but this the pacing of it is very
it's not slow
necessarily but it's it's just it's very
deliberately paced
i will say that it's very deliberately
based everything is just
goes along at a very stately well
they're not pushing you through it
yeah they're not rushing it it's going
through at the rate that it should go
and to give you a feeling of like you're
there and that you're
you're you're in on this to me
the movie reminded me of
the trailers of national treasure i've
never seen the movie national treasure
oh what the nicholas kate the nicholas
cage you know how he's
finding the secrets behind this and that
yeah see i like movies like that
although i've never seen it i don't
think i've ever seen that movie or if i
have oh yeah i have yeah i have i just
didn't remember that much i've never
seen it i played the video game
but i never seen it all right and and
this movie kind of reminded me of the
trailer
yeah national treasure all right i don't
know if that movie's any good that's
maybe that's something i ought to see
eventually i mean
you probably like it like i said i've
seen it one time like right around when
it came out like maybe a year or two
later and i remember
liking it but not not making that much
imagine if stanley kubrick
did the tr the trailer to national
treasure
that's kind of way the feeling yeah okay
yeah you understand that i'm vibing with
that
trying to give the feel of them yeah
it's like that
this is like you said it is kind of
kubricky and but it also has kind of a
noir
yeah sort of thing to it and i like to
like this the whole color palette of it
the score everything it kind of
i don't know it has a really nice color
palette that it uses i can't really
explain it it's not
soft it's yeah it's like not subdued
necessarily but it kind of it's very
like rich and velvety
yeah you know what i mean the came out
in 2000 i think right
1999 1999 okay the decor most of the
stuff is very 90s like [ __ ] from 95 96 a
lot of [ __ ] from 94.
that's what's in the sets or the
apartment like in his apartment yeah
yeah
even the clothes is very 90s the
haircuts
but it looks really good in this format
you know it was kind of like the height
of the 90s stuff
the the the color palettes that was used
inside of [ __ ] cutting-edge
apartments and stuff it just it was kind
of
cool to see that again you know i was
like yeah i remember that
nice [ __ ] looked like that yeah back in
the 90s you know what i mean like uh
somebody's apartment down in boston or
something you know if they were
professional that's the way their dad
apartment looked
same color schemes stuff just kind of
neat yeah
and the clothes the clothes were kind of
just nondescript
they were they closed their style was is
not to have a [ __ ] style
that's the only way i can describe it
yeah it didn't look 70s it didn't look
80s it didn't even look too thousands it
was just
them damn wool pants and the [ __ ]
shirts and the
you're to wear a sweater and then you
can have a jacket it's just you know
what i mean
everything was kind of subdued and
dialed back because i think the 70s and
the 80s were kind of real over the top
yeah
so i think everyone was just kind of
like sick of all that like excess i just
wanted to look normal again
90s uh uh mundane clothes for just
regular people were real
kind of plain in a way yeah just kind of
generic
kind of a generic look to them they look
like something that would
be on a [ __ ] photograph inside a
corporate
brochure showing you houses or something
you know i mean it's just what it looked
like to me
yeah you know i mean although i didn't i
mean the clothes in this didn't really
like pop out to me yeah they're generic
yeah that's what i mean but in a way
that's good because it kind of
keeps it's not distracting yeah you it
was
if you were to tell me that it came out
in 2008 i'd say okay
yeah yeah it wouldn't really it really
wouldn't matter because everything like
you said everything but he just kind of
had plain suits or like you know
when they go to like lena owen's
character she just has kind of a black
you know like nice pantsuit or whatever
that you could probably wear nowadays
yeah it's hard to place it in time other
than the cars
you know driving around and [ __ ] like
dodge vipers and stuff
you know it's it's hard to put it the
the film did not become dated
it aged very well yeah it did it didn't
really seem all that dated to me other
than like a little bit of ropey green
screening like in
you know just in the car scenes like
where they're driving like in the new
york scenes
but on but honestly you know that's just
like the first maybe
20 30 minutes of the movie and then it
goes to europe and it was shot in
portugal spain france uh [ __ ] like that
and all that [ __ ] was obviously
certain ways it is dated because modern
hollywood of the past [ __ ] five
ten years is not as coherent as this
yeah this is storytelling is very good
this is a surprisingly
focused yeah i mean it's it's long and
like i said it's very deliberately paced
but everything happens for a reason
everything happens you know this thing
happens and so he goes on and does the
other thing
and it's a very deliberate you know uh
investigation because the first thing
he's doing he has to go to europe he's
like okay well
uh first i'm gonna look into the person
that owned you know
boris's book before so he goes and
checks her out
and then um you know then he goes to
europe and he wants to see
you know the other people that have had
it and the people that had it before
them because he's trying to get all this
information about it
now along the way and i don't even think
we've mentioned this much other than uh
right at the beginning along the way he
starts suspecting that
boris has maybe hired this mysterious
woman who was never named in the movie
she's just called the girl in the
credits
and um she keeps like turning up man
like the first time she sees
the first time he sees her is in new
york
at uh the boris boris balkan lecture
that he's giving about demonology and
witchcraft or whatever
and uh then he sees her on a train in
portugal or spain and he's like hey like
he so he at first assumes
that boris has hired her to follow him
around to make sure he's doing what he's
supposed to be doing i'm thinking that's
what he
i don't think he ever says that outright
but i'm saying i think that
she's a [ __ ] private investigator
yeah that she's following him around
however as the movie goes on you
discover
that there's a a lot more to that woman
yeah then
he had some paranormal abilities yeah
which i really you know what i love the
way that's introduced because for a long
time
you just he keeps seeing her and it's a
little bit weird because like he sees
her in a library like through this crack
in the books and then
you know he looks again and she's not
there like but you know it plausible
deniability she could have run away
but then he gets attacked by the
boyfriend of
the woman that used to own boris's book
um you know there's a whole thing there
because she's kind of like
trying to [ __ ] get the books too and
she's willing to like kill people
but the this woman who he ends up
calling green eyes
like because she won't uh tell him her
name she shows up
and starts kicking the dude's ass and
there's just a shot she's walking down
the stair
like steps outside and then she flies
like she just goes shh
yeah it's more like glide yeah she like
kind of glides down
and it's like really jarring that's like
really really it came down to steps
without touching them
yeah and just actually levitated yeah
yeah it's pretty it looked good it
looked good though i just really i well
i liked the way that they just kind of
like because you're led to believe
that she's a person and she does have
human qualities too because in that
fight
like she does kick that dude's ass but
he does like elbow her in the face and
her nose starts to bleed
so she's obviously not completely
supernatural but she has supernatural
powers well i thought she was a
either an angel or a demon yeah like
that it's it's resolved later what she
is
but yeah she's basically and there it's
weird because there's this one channel i
can't remember what it's called
but this dude made several several
videos that were like eight or nine
minutes long
just um going into various aspects of
this movie
like in different theories about it and
who she was
now at first you kind of think you know
once her
supernatural abilities are established
and she also kind of has something of
uh not she she's like has psychic powers
kind of like she knows things
that there's no possible way that she
can know she turns up places where he is
and he can't figure out you know what i
mean she disappears real quick
and [ __ ] like that so you know that
there's something supernatural about her
but she does say something at one point
because they start kind of teaming up
and working together and he
jokes that oh you're my guardian angel
and she says something like that
so but then as the story goes on i don't
know
well i don't know she could be a
guardian angel but i think she's maybe a
demon
gee but maybe maybe that's not a bad
thing demons are angels
yeah well that's what i mean she's kind
of like yeah
yeah you have to make the you have to um
make that you call yourself when you see
the end of the movie yeah i
definitely do think i mean she's
obviously has something to do with
i think she's kind of neutral in between
like a demon well she's helping johnny
depp yeah
because the thing about it is that i
chose him over the other ones
yeah because the thing about it is that
what boris balkan
is trying to do is he's actually trying
to get all the books together
because in each of the books there are
all these uh woodcuts like these
illustrations
and the reason he wanted to compare his
copy to the other two copies in europe
was that he wanted to see there's
there's like little bitty differences in
the what
he didn't actually know you remember he
was like checking he said
yeah he said he wanted to see the other
two books and he wanted to care
he's he wanted johnny depp i'm gonna
call him johnny depp well yeah so
he wanted to that's it carefully compare
the two to see if there were any
differences
yeah and it was demonstrated early on
once he meets the twins
which you got to see the movie there's
that i'm talking about they showed him
that
the text was identical even the errors
in the text
there's an s that was [ __ ] up in it is
the exact same text
so deps started going to the wood cuts
so there must be a difference in these
pictures and he did notice that there
were differences
little stuff like scissors and in the
right hand and one wood cut yeah were
they keys or scissors like
these i think they were keys in the left
hand and then they sewed certain parts
of pictures of walls and mazes and
sometimes the doors were open and one
would cut the other in the other in the
other print
uh the door had been like bricked out
ripped over
and then the signature at the bottom
was different one of them i don't want
to spoil all of it because then
then you're because it's kind of the
puzzles behind the meaning of this well
that's kind of what makes it fun
there was differences in the pictures
yeah and the dif
you had to know the differences in the
pictures in order to do this right
yes ritual to open up the to the ninth
gate
where satan was he's like
i'm in here i'm trapped so you
one copy wasn't enough you had to have
all three
yeah yeah which is something that kind
of comes out but you know even knowing
that
um i still think it's a really good
watch because i just like
i don't know i like all that and you
know and like i said as johnny depp goes
through things and starts solving the
mystery
um you know all the the other people
that own the books like other people
that are just kind of like you know
uh kind of on the margins or whatever
get murdered
um you know the book gets stolen at some
point and so it's so it's just kind of
like i like that you sort of compared it
to national treasure it's like
like are they like the da vinci code or
something like that but not as like
cheesy
no is that necessarily so the guy that
hired johnny depp
he wasn't a hundred percent sure he just
knew that the book that he had was
authentic
all right and he believed that it would
work
but he tried it and it didn't work i
love that scene too
look at that so he wanted to see the
other two copies
to see if there were any if there were
you know if there were any differences
because if there were differences that
might answer
why his opening of the ninth gate didn't
work and yeah it was
that found out quickly that there were
differences in those pictures and the
and
the guy who hired him instantly knew it
was like okay i need them all
yeah i need all of them then because you
can't just see he already thought of it
yeah i guess he had already thought of
that that there that you you might need
more than one book
and i feel like throughout the course of
the movie too you're led to believe that
boris
he's not supernatural or anything but
he's for sure following johnny depp
around
because he'll he'll call him and johnny
depp's
be like where are you where are you and
he's just like won't answer him
so i think he was following him the
whole time as well or using some
kind of psychic abilities or uh because
he did show up
like at the end too so he i think he had
been like following him the whole time
and because at first as i said you think
that the
the green eyes girl you know the mystery
woman you think that she's following
johnny depp around on that guy's behalf
but you you find out as the story goes
on that that's not exactly what's
happening he may have had
some uh satanic abilities himself
because
why else why else would you know that
that'd be the only explanation of why he
believed in that book so much
yeah so he had seen some supernatural
[ __ ]
yeah i mean he yeah he must have because
and like you said yeah i did i do think
that it was kind of i don't know if it
stated outright or if it was implied
that he had tried to like summon the
devil before with just his book and it
didn't work
so maybe he said oh well maybe this
isn't you know maybe this one isn't the
the real one or whatever so maybe he
didn't know that that's what was going
to happen when he sent johnny depp out
on the mission
i don't yeah he he he wasn't really sure
he wasn't sure
yeah it was implied during that initial
conversation that he did try to open the
ninth gate and that it didn't work
yeah he wanted the other books yeah to
see if to see if there were any
differences
because the differences might have been
the key the reason why
yeah and then he found out that there
were differences and he was okay i need
all the books
yeah and at that point he tries to like
give johnny depp a bunch more money
and he doesn't say outright um yeah he
he just says something like you need to
get them
like at any cost yeah he means you could
kill this yeah
and then johnny depp's like yeah i'm i
i've never done anything that illegal
he's
and then he's just add another zero
under the end of your
painting add another zero you know he
did that a couple times
yeah so he was offering him tens of
millions of dollars
i'm imagining they never tell you how
much but i like that too because it
doesn't date the movie yeah well he's
looks at he looked at it he was kind of
stunned at how much money it was when he
first saw that check yeah but they never
tell you what it is yeah
and he says add another zero and then he
added another zero so it must have been
tens of millions if not hundreds of
millions i mean you
because the dude was filthy rich and
according to the other satanist woman
the one in the wheelchair
she said that her and the other
satanists
believed that their wealth was due
to them being in this cult yeah of
satanist that it was satan that was
giving him this
all this wealth yeah that's right she
did say that
yeah the barrel they believed in this
yeah yeah and well i mean evidence
evidently
yeah i really did like the way this was
kind of result like like i said it's
almost kind of like
some of the people were shitty like i
said you know boris was a shitty person
because obviously you know he killed
people to get what he wanted and lena
olin's character was also shitty because
she would all
was also willing to kill people to get
what she wanted because i think it was
her that killed that other bookseller
like in new york
my my during the time i was watching the
movie i got the impression that they
were
what you called back in the 70s satanic
witches
yeah all right kind of like in the movie
uh the legacy from what was that 1978-79
yeah where yeah they actually did have
[ __ ] these
satanic powers witchcraft they could
kill you
make you you know what i mean curse you
and die and you would die
yeah or they would kill you in weird
ways like make a damn mirror explode and
you get hit with a bunch of shards
or the fire leaps out of the fire or
make you
yeah jump in the pool and then when you
try to get back up you can't break
through the surface of the water you
drown
yeah they could do stuff like that that
was a good movie yeah
yeah we did a review of that before but
yeah it was kind of like the same these
these people struck me i mean lena olin
had her little uh
group with all the robes and everything
but the other
satanist like boris and the cat and the
baroness and them
they seemed more like just random like
just people that were really interested
in the occult and were interested in
satanism not so much
you know in a cult they were kind of
like freewheeling and that one guy that
owned it vargas i think his name was the
guy that ended up uh drowned in the pond
i think that guy uh didn't really
believe in it he had one of the books
but just because he was a book collector
and he had a [ __ ] ton of them and he was
interested in
occult books but i don't think he
believed in any of that
you know what i'm saying so he wasn't in
on in on all the two twins weren't
satanists
the the guys that were book dealers yeah
they weren't satanists but they believed
it
yeah remember that yeah they were like
no no he was with the devil they were
they were laughing
dude the devil did write that book yeah
but then
and then it turns out later they were
part of the plot twist not really a plot
twist
they had made sure they had done some
[ __ ] to try to make sure you couldn't
open a gate
yeah so yeah and yeah actually now that
you uh yeah that way yeah that one page
yeah yeah that's how that turned out but
so um i kind of feel like like i said i
don't really want to spoil the ending
i feel like some people didn't really
like the ending this
it's weird because this movie came out
it didn't make a
[ __ ] ton of money it made its money back
in the u.s
um it kind of got real mixed reviews
some people just thought it was kind of
meh or like it went on too long or
whatever spoiled back then i think that
well it got better um it got a better
reception in europe i think um
you know i think they were more into it
uh american audiences just didn't
love it i mean like i said it didn't
lose money this came out in a time when
hollywood had made it already made a
bunch of good movies
the 10 years prior so it was a high time
for hollywood
they were pickier and but the thing is
the critics were always full of [ __ ]
there was had this come out recently the
critics would have liked it probably
i don't think they would have um yeah
and like i said people would have liked
it better
yeah the audiences were spoiled back
then and i think too
this is a movie that maybe kind of like
eyes wide shut because the first time i
saw eyes wide shuck because this kind of
reminds me of that a little bit and it
reminds me like i said of
dario argento's inferno a little bit too
not as wacky as that but it's kind of
along the same lines
i kind of feel like this is one of those
ones that you see it the first time you
see it and it's like
pretty good but it's like underwhelming
but then if you see it again
you're like oh like because you pick up
on a lot more stuff this is definitely
one that i think if you saw it a long
time ago
and you didn't love it you'd probably
like it you should probably watch it
again because i saw in the theater and i
remember liking it but i couldn't
remember hardly anything about it i said
all i remember about this because you
asked me i said i think it's about
satanist in a book i think that's all i
remembered yeah and um
you know pretty much and so so i really
like like watching it again and i'm like
wait that's way way better than i just
fit in real good with like i said eyes
wide shut and maybe like heredity
hereditary hereditary and i saw the move
i fell asleep in it
but like those the ones with the uh the
more of kind of the satanic overtones
yeah it's just right there with that
yeah i mean if you were to remake it
today that they would do it more like
hereditary
probably is it called hereditary or yeah
hereditary
you say it wrong every single time
[Laughter]
i just say things wrong there's nothing
i'm [ __ ] watching movies i'm not a
scholar
i want to see that one again though i
can't sleep in it
yeah i well i'm gonna do it again
because zach keeps asking me to do it
for my show and i've told him i do want
to do it for my
show um for my flickers of beer show you
can even star if you want to if you like
it if you if you're just going to [ __ ]
on it no
then no um but i'm i told him i said and
i and i
don't say this about many movies that
movie stressed me out so much when i
watch it the first time that i'm anxious
i want to watch it again
and i don't want to watch it again
because it made me so anxious what's
funny is that i didn't really like that
when i fell asleep in it
all right but i want to give it a second
shot it might have been my mind state at
the time
yeah um because sometimes your mindset
really affects how you see something
um i didn't like that one but i liked
mid-summer a lot
yeah you know and i think that
you would probably think that i would
that that i would have liked mid-summer
even less
i thought that while we were watching i
said oh you're really going to hate this
one
i want both of those on blu-ray yeah i
definitely actually want to watch
hereditary even though i'm like
even though i know what's coming and
that somehow like makes it worse it's
like i don't know it's just like a
really anxiety interesting baby for me
and i'm not the only person that said
that you know what i mean i've seen like
a bunch of other videos because i know
there's like always those edgelords
others
that wasn't scary i woke up during the
creepy parts yeah
yeah well but you really have to kind of
you really have
this is one of those movies and i've
said this before if you're going to
watch a horror movie if you're going to
watch
actually if you're going to watch any
movie uh you know unless it's just some
fun thing that you can drink beers or
whatever
if you're going to like commit to
watching a movie like that
then just let yourself like be immersed
in it let
let it scare you that's what it's trying
to do you know what i mean let yourself
get into the characters let yourself i
mean if you can't then that's fine
but i'm just saying that i don't like
people
that watch they'll watch horror movies
but then at the end
that wasn't scary that was dumb but but
the reason that they do that is because
they're closing themselves off they're
not letting themselves
get immersed in the story or you know
what i mean yeah
so so it's for them yeah it's not going
to be scary because they're just like
they close themselves off and they don't
care so it's like why watch it
then there was just something about the
tone of hereditary when i first saw it
i was watching it and the the the little
girl that was doing the [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] i was like come on man
and it was and i didn't like her
and when the car smashed her head off
and [ __ ] i let
the timing and the way it was it was it
happened so fast
and because i didn't really like her i
laughed at the time and a lot of people
thought it was unappropriate
but that was my reaction i was like yeah
yeah [ __ ] her and then i fell asleep
right after it
yeah yeah i don't know why just he was
in one of his moods
i just it looked funny to me one of his
little it just no it just looked funny
to me
i had to see it again though yeah see it
again
i mean that little girl was weird for
sure yeah she was she like she was
creepy though that little girl
yeah and when her head got smashed i i
enjoyed it so i was just like yeah
[ __ ] that jake and then and then i felt
better and fell asleep
i guess but then i woke up and there was
all kinds of weird satanic displays of
like dead bodies and [ __ ] and i was like
oh man it's [ __ ] weird
i woke up during one time where uh
uh shauna was with us
like that and i woke up to see somebody
crawling across the ceiling
yeah yeah i was like yeah that's pretty
cool one of the best things about
hereditary and like i said i didn't even
you got to like watch a bunch of videos
about this there's so much [ __ ] in here
that the first time you watch it you
didn't notice there's so much [ __ ] going
on in the background
there's all kind of symbolism that you
didn't notice just like in mid-summer
they did that too
yeah but it's like there's people in the
background that you don't notice
it's just like it's so so creepy oh my
god i can't even believe how much effort
like arya astor put into that [ __ ] like
putting all that stuff in the background
that you probably weren't even gonna
notice
but if you like see videos of it and
they point out every single time that
there's somebody standing back in the
shadows or there's somebody standing out
on the lawn that you didn't see or some
[ __ ] like that it's like super super
creepy
but like you i think part of your brain
picks up on it which
you know even though i didn't notice the
people um i think my brain
part of my brain was picking up on it
because that's what was causing me such
anxiety like this whole [ __ ] movie
was that my brain was like there's
people there's people everywhere oh my
god it was kind of like that
but yeah so so this movie uh the ninth
gate
it's you know not it i feel like it's it
kind of has a rosemary's baby vibe too
i mean you know with the whole satanic
cult angle and whatnot yeah kind of yeah
um
you know but just if you haven't if you
haven't seen it or if you just saw it a
long time ago and you didn't really care
for it
i would suggest watching it again i mean
because i really really liked it
much better the second time i didn't
hate it the first time it's just i
i liked it at the time but it didn't
make much of an impression like i didn't
remember much about it i didn't see it
at the time
yeah see i saw it in the theater like i
i distinctly remember going to the
theater today trying to put myself
my mindset back in 99 what was
i don't think i would have liked it as
much in 99 i think you have to be a
little bit older to understand to to
appreciate this movie
yeah maybe a little bit of an older
audience i would i think
i don't know maybe i would have enjoyed
it i saw eyes wide shut
before this that eyes wide shut came out
when like well it's weird because i
think eyes wide shut came out the same
year and same year
because i saw that one and liked it so
it's really weird how there was like a
weird synergy going on between us
because one couldn't rip off the other
one because i think they were making
them at the same time i saw eyes wide
shut in the theater and i liked it
i saw that in the theater as well yeah i
liked it and a lot of people didn't
really seem to like it although it was
getting a lot of hype
people go going it was kubrick's last
movie you know i mean so obviously
that's going to be a lot to live up to
yeah i was watching it and i i had a
good time watching it
i did too i didn't like it as much as
other ones i still don't but
um you know what i mean i that's the
thing i kind of like about doing
this show and like revisiting some of
these movies that maybe we saw once like
along like 20 years ago and forgot about
is that sometimes i mean you get an
entire
it's recontextualizes the entire movie
for you because when you saw it the
first time like when i saw this back in
1999 like my [ __ ]
entire you know life was different and
even though i dug it
i kind of forgot about it but so like
you get to watch it again just from a
totally different perspective
and it's almost kind of like seeing it
again as a new movie that you're a
little bit familiar with
you sure that i have wide shut came out
in 99 i'm pretty sure
i thought it came out a little bit
before that i'm pretty sure it was 99
yeah i was i thought i was in boston
when that happened
i left boston around 97 i was pretty
sure it was 1999.
maybe i mean it could have been 98 [ __ ]
now i can't even remember
yeah do you have you don't have your
tablet with you so you can't check
because i was like because he always
kind of does that hey what is it i'm
like i don't know i don't know i'm not
google
like sometimes i can remember but i was
pretty sure that eyes wide shut
and the ninth gate came out the same
year okay i could be wrong
but i they came out like right around
the same time okay
i thought but i could be wrong i know we
even reviewed eyes watch that not too
long ago
no i can't even remember i can't keep
this straight on all this [ __ ] i can't
yeah
it's funny because i remember old [ __ ]
more than you know what i mean like i
remember
the year that you know movies that came
out in the 70s and 80s i usually
remember that better
than more recent because the more recent
it's just kind of like a smeary blur
you know what i mean but yeah so this
movie is on
actually it's on pretty much every
platform we watch on amazon prime it's
free on there it's on hulu
uh i think it's even on 2b so you can
watch for free with commercials
so uh yeah if you if you dig like other
room and polanski movies and you haven't
seen this one or you haven't seen it a
long time
like check it out it's like kind of a
cool mystery noir
type of thing and like i said it's about
ancient satanic books and who doesn't
love that i certainly love that
but yeah so we will see you guys on the
next one
bye
you